the franca foundations Southwest of the
German capital formed the largest
educational complex in Europe some 300
years ago a Lutheran pastor named August
Herman franca founded a charity school
here in Halle on the salah and an
orphanage next to it the charity school
soon earned a good reputation and franca
found generous donors for his project
the orphanage erected in 1701 was
enormous for its time it is the mother
house of the foundations which have
developed into a town within the town
there are now no fewer than 50
institutions on the property which
provide 5,000 people with accommodation
and employment Frank had developed
pedagogical ideas that have shaped the
German school system and spread across
the world his starting point was
Luther's belief that everyone should be
able to read the Bible in their own
language and the Good Book is still at
the center of the foundation
I will come on Frank attack me together
yeah caucus chairman franca was inspired
by the ideas of the Reformation he
resolved to apply Luther's vision to his
own time we see this very clearly in his
attitude to the Bible Martin Luther has
dreamed of placing a Bible in every
person's hands but that was technically
impossible in the 16th century
[Music]
[Music]
the can't stand biblical Institute was
founded in 1710 pastor Volta Rehan is a
former director at the center
the hair shilling their people about
suicide in Luther's time printing was
simply too expensive poor people
couldn't afford a Bible barren canteen
and August franca hit on the idea of
fixed type which was invented in Holland
they had each page of the Bible typeset
in lead it was a very costly process
requiring five million letters but
afterwards they no longer needed a
typesetter they only needed a printer I
have a copy of the Bible they produced
here it's housed in a slip case it
appears to have been in a fire at some
time but the case protected the volumes
it's a can Stein Bible from 1770 with a
very plain design they were cheap copies
which cost only six or eight groschen
each equivalent to a day's wages for a
trained craftsman of course the library
also contains precious in Kunar Beulah
and facsimile editions the historic
library where the books of stack
contains 120,000 printed works in
various languages it's the largest of
its kind in Europe however Franco was
not only a theologian and educator he
was also a good businessman the franca
foundations received Royal patents in
the 17th century they operated a
printing shop bookstores and a
profitable pharmacy activities that
financed the orphanage but the orphans
were the main focus of Franca's work and
that is still true of the foundation
today apart from reading and writing
franca placed emphasis on practical
experience in the children's creative
center the kids are encouraged to
participate in various activities what
was life like in this orphanage 300
years ago or how was printing invented
the children learn with practical
examples
but mind you um what do you think we'll
be working with today when you see these
things lettuce lettuce where do you know
them from from the Bible so how do you
think the letters were put into such an
old book written curious children and
their families can give free rein to
their creativity here they can learn new
things talk experiment relax and play
focusing on the historical treasures of
the Frank of foundations and the special
exhibitions at the historical orphanage
journeys of exploration into the past
are organized daily learning about
history becomes an exciting adventure
the games often have a religious aspect
just as in Frank Oz day the founder was
an apostle of Pietism a religious
movement that evolved in Germany in the
late 17th century
it was the most significant movement
since the Reformation with a strong
emphasis on the Bible
[Music]
that's why the teacher here doesn't only
focus on technology but sees to it that
as many biblical verses appear on the
printing plates as possible these words
are written so that you may believe that
Jesus is the Christ the Son of God and
that by believing you may have life in
his name
just as in a real print shop
everything here is cleaned before the
lesson ends when the children are groups
visit us to take part in the museum's
educational programs we first explain
what an extraordinary place this is
about the people who worked here and the
meaning of this little school town how
necessary it is and how relevant its
social and cultural contribution is the
first part is landed in southern India
in 1709 in tranquil bar now called
Teheran gam body battle Emmaus diggin
bug on Heinrich blue cow was sent by the
Danish King to spread Luther's message
beyond the borders of Europe showing
respect sensitivity and genuine interest
they sought dialogue with the Indians
first they learnt the local language and
explored the territory today they are
revered as the Guru's of printing in
India
ziegenbock house is currently being
restored with financial assistance from
the German government as a museum for
the history of intercultural dialogue
[Music]
does Internet's vanish tracking let's
test from the international network that
stretched from Germany and England to
Tehran gum body clearly can be presented
in this room gosh tie together yes mean
apart is a museum education officer from
hala she's helping to develop the museum
in its initial stages the aim is to
present the fusion of culture and
history from two continents the method
adopted follows the principle of
learning by doing
[Music]
once I was the young joy we want the
museum to be a place in which everybody
feels welcome the work with school
children is therefore a very important
part here in South India the principal
was always the same as in hala providing
education for orphans and poor children
thus giving them a future early on the
missionaries translated the Bible into
Tamil Bible studies are still an
essential part of the curriculum
but sport is also part of the mix the
longer I'm here the more I feel accepted
by the people every visitor to India is
welcomed with a broad smile
the adults are interested and so are the
children they surround you and want to
know how you're doing and where you're
from it wasn't always that way
pastored ziegenbock had to win their
confidence his worst adversaries were
the people he called godless Europeans
today he's revered in India for his
remarkable achievements his statue in
gold shines over Tarakan body his
printing shops spread throughout India
orphanages were founded all over the
country and schools for boys and girls
his birthday is being celebrated in a
special way this year
[Music]
[Music]
the director of the franca foundations
Thomas Mueller Barker and his wife are
visiting tarragon body they've bought a
paper cutting machine for the museum
from Germany
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's already a printing press here so
materials can produce just as they were
in Siegen baths time there are panels
explaining the history of the orphanage
[Music]
[Applause]
the restoration work is not finished for
the German Foreign Ministry has donated
fifty thousand euros to the project
[Music]
Mira Barca is invited to plant a
commemorative Luther tree in front of
the museum
[Music]
back to the Frank of foundations in
Germany guests have arrived from all
over the world to mark the birthday of
August Herman franca the celebrations
begin with a choral anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dear friends and donors of the franca
foundations ladies and gentlemen at the
heart of this annual celebration is the
commemoration of Auguste franca at the
founders memorial on the plinth dated
1829 we read the epitaph he trusted God
[Music]
alkis Franca's motto was to the glory of
God to be of use to people those words
still inspire the staff and donors of
the franca foundations the commemoration
has the character of a state funeral and
indeed franca was something of a
statesman with a keen business sense he
pursued his social ideas and with
educational insights he transformed the
school system trusting in God he made
himself useful to the common people
especially the poor
his ideas have borne fruit all over the
world but Halle remains the center of
his legacy the annual commemoration is
also a forum for international dialogue
[Music]
professor Daniel J Raj holds doctoral
degrees from both Indian and German
universities he's especially interested
in intercultural and inter-religious
issues this alumnus of the franca
foundations is an expert on Bartolomeo
Stephen bug the First Lutheran
missionary in India
[Music]
the slepen bigger air above and Sigyn
but sagan bugs living legacy is the vibe
there were Catholic missionaries before
him and they translated a lot into Tamil
but it wasn't available to the average
person the Lutheran Sagan bulk placed it
in the hands of ordinary folk so they
could read it in their own language and
think about it themselves and reevaluate
their situation yes mean effort has come
from India to attend the Frank of
commemoration she trained as a museum
education officer here in Halle before
being sent out Tudor and embody
des Poisson over on August 7 I think
what made oldest Hermann Frank is so
special was his far-reaching vision for
one thing it inspired the international
relations that Franco was able to
establish beyond India his international
network stretching from India to Russia
and on to America is an impressive
achievement even today what is enough
just as these German children are
learning the significance of franca and
Siegen bargain holla
Jasleen effort will soon be teaching the
same history to children in India
and do you know what his profession was
and one pastor very good yes August
Herman franca studied theology religion
and became a pastor
obviously the staff of the Frank of
foundations are very proud of their
founder but some young visitors still
need a little persuading
[Music]
the oldest hammock frank august hammond
franca had a great idea the
schoolchildren needed lots of books so
he simply set up his own printing shop
to make them affordable with the help of
his staff he printed the books himself
here on the property he also sold some
of them and used the money to buy things
for instance items he needed for
teaching had a ton Peter whom
undergirding a golf diamond somebody
fitted onto his Papa after the children
have climbed the stairs in the old
orphanage to the treasure trove in the
Attic there are a lot more enthusiastic
it's called the crocus iam but there's
more than just a crocodile here all
sorts of exotic souvenirs were brought
back from all the territories to which
the Frank of foundation sent
missionaries
[Music]
here there are loads of things for the
children to discover and it's impossible
to answer all their questions
[Music]
[Music]
I'd be the digger August Herman franca
showed all these things to the school
children during lessons and when the
king asked him why he taught the
children about such things he said so
they won't stand like oxen in front of a
gate should they ever encounter them in
life this shows his ideal that people
should have a broad general knowledge
that was new in the history of art
galleries and curiosity cabinets they
were usually constructed for the
pleasure and edification of their owners
Franco was the first person to use a
curiosity cabinet to teach
schoolchildren
visits many of the old items are fragile
and visitors are no longer allowed to
touch them but these children can still
look at the originals and draw them
later they will work with models or
mock-ups in the classroom it's a
hands-on approach to learning
experiencing the world in 3d has been
the secret of the Frank of foundations
teaching success for 300 years it's
something that distinguishes us in our
history from other teaching institutions
we have other ways of presenting
material we're able to refer back to a
real history and background this is
something that appeals to children we're
not telling stories that hover in the
air like fairy tales we focus on a real
person and an idea that has continued
developing here you can see the living
result of creating something through the
strength of faith I think that's
something our children can learn from
sometimes the children can also take
things home things they themselves have
discovered learned about and tried out
this was also one of Franca's ideas to
encourage the individual personality
along with the conscious social
development of young people in my whom
is this might be considered one of the
first secondary schools in Germany for
the first time front has systematically
used visual teaching aids so this is a
very special location in the history of
schooling in defences of pedagogy
country will be shaky against his own
heart children are also expected to sit
still sometimes and focus their
attention a good story helps so a local
author reading his own work is a welcome
visitor the children in the crocoseum
are riveted
[Music]
the life of a fly is very short so why
be grumpycat distraught I will sing you
a song of flies steal your sleep before
one dies she closes in as if to tease
plucks your whiskers if you please for
this the tease will have to pay but the
flies already flown away vbeq after
quietly listening for a while it's time
for the children to get active again and
invent their own stories I'm the moon
and she's the star and we're talking to
each other we say like how are you today
and then we ask each other something and
that leads to a conversation
[Music]
[Music]
damn computer does this
[Music]
when youth should we talk about our
qualities one of my qualities is that I
light up the dark and one of my
characteristics is that I'm awake at
night and that's how we became friends
[Applause]
our aim is to change the world a bit I
won't say make it better although of
course we would like to do that we
invest in the children here and show
them how it's possible to live together
and create a valuable and respectful
climate of coexistence this
distinguishes us from other institutions
because of our history or - hide it when
an enriched in the medieval script
aurilla all the scribes sat in one room
but each had to master calligraphy for
himself the young monks were taught the
basics of writing in the monasteries but
they would have to practice for years
before they were allowed to make copies
of the Bible and other books
the invention of the printing press
changed all that
[Music]
of course Martin Luther also wrote text
by hand but without the printing press
his translation of the Bible into German
would have reached very few readers it
is now commonly accepted without that
media revolution the Reformation would
not have occurred done to become Viva
and into a fountain so there are
parallels to our own times in which the
new media possibilities have permeated
society and are changing it
yeah divides and commits offend nuns of
what us it happened in Luther's time 500
years ago and he saw an opportunity to
spread access to the Bible franca
continued that work in the spirit of
Luther
[Music]
you